so let me give you a really really
simple example of a differential a
private technique for one task so
suppose you have a big lecture hall
filled with you know 500 students or
something and you want to know what
fraction of them cheated on at least one
exam during their first year so you want
to ask them about an Abba havior that's
not only embarrassing but probably a
violation of honor code and you could
give them the following instructions
it's if you know it's going to give them
a method of plausible deniability
basically so the instructions are as
follows the first flip a coin don't tell
me the outcome of the coin if the coin
came up heads answer the question
truthfully if the coin came up tails
flip another coin and if the second coin
came up heads say yes and otherwise say
no so you see that a student who never
cheated still has a 1/4 probability of
saying I cheated and a student who
cheated still has a 1/4 probability of
thing I didn't cheat and so you can
gather up now these basically randomized
responses but randomized with a bias
toward the truth randomize responses to
your query and you do a little bit of
reverse engineering and you can get a
close approximation to the true fraction
of students who cheated during at some
point during their first year assuming
they follow the instructions correctly
and that's called randomize response and
it's a technique that was developed in
1965 by Stanley Warner and differential
privacy actually assigns a formal
measure of privacy lost there that's
associated with the ratio of the
probable
of producing say the answer of yes when
the truth is yes versus when the truth
is no and it turns out that differential
privacy will tell you this is the
logarithm of three differentially
private that's our epsilon for that
procedure you could make it more privacy
protective by increasing the chances
that they will answer randomly and
decreasing the chances that they answer
truthfully by instead of starting with a
fair coin starting with a coin that's
biased toward telling them to answer
randomly and that oddly this thing
randomized response is fancy versions of
it that's what is being used by Apple
now in iOS 10 and also by Google and the
in for certain things in the Chrome
browser